Véronique Genest
as-tu déjà pensé à épouser Navarro pour
faire 60% de part de marché
Véronique vous savez ce qui vous attend
maintenant
une interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
oh là là dure la loupiote
est-ce que tu crois en Dieu oui
as-tu peur d'aller en enfer sur le câble
[Rires]
as-tu déjà regardé TF1 le samedi soir
oui tous les samedis soirs as-tu déjà
regardé un film porno en y prenant du
plaisir
je dis la vérité
là c'est le jugement dernier à mon avis
à mon avis tu as pas le choix de toute
façon allez ouais
après
c'est un truc dans un escalier c'est fou
l'effet que ça fait les escaliers
c'est un fantasme terrible avec un
ascenseur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sur une autre chaîne et de se faire
traiter de cochonnes de palmier
de grosses mais que je ne paierai jamais
Véronique Genest
as-tu déjà pensé à épouser Navarro pour
faire 60% de part de marché
non parce qu'on serait pas qu'il fait
as-tu déjà menti sur ton âge oh oui
alors j'arrête pas d'ailleurs tu t'es
planté tout à l'heure
as-tu incité des gens à manger du porc
non mais qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par
inciter à manger du porc de la pub pour
des jambes ah c'est ça en fait
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu